what was your favorite feature of python
do you remember like what yeah
it's so interesting
to linger on like the
what
what really makes you connect with the
language i'm not sure it's
obvious to introspect that no it isn't
and i've i've thought about that at some
length i'm not i think definitely the
fact that i could read it later yeah
that i could use it productively without
becoming an expert and the other
language i had to put more effort into
right because that's like an empirical
observation like you're not analyzing
any one aspect of language it just seems
time after time you look back it's
somehow readable it's somewhat readable
then it was sort of i could take
uh executable english yeah and translate
it to python more easily like i didn't
have to go there was no translation
layer
as an engineer or as a scientist i could
think about what i wanted to do and then
the syntax wasn't that far behind it
yeah right now there are some there have
some there's some warts there still it
wasn't perfect like there's some areas
where i'm like uh i'd be better if this
were different or if this were different
some of those things got out of the
language too i was really grateful for
some of the early pioneers in the python
ecosystem back because python got
written in 91 is when the first version
came out but guido was very open to
users and one of the sets of users were
people like jim hughnin and david asher
and paul dubois
and
conrad hinson these were people that
were on the main list and they were just
asking for things like hey we really
should have complex numbers in this
language so let's you know there's a j
there's a one j right and the fact that
they went the engineering root of j is
interesting
i
don't i don't think that's entirely
favorite engineers i think it's because
i is so often used as the index of a for
loop
so i think that's actually
probably right i mean there's there's a
pragmatic aspect like the complex
numbers were there i love that the fact
that i could write nd arrays constructs
and that reduction was there very simple
to write summations and and and
broadcasting was there i could do
addition of whole arrays um so that was
cool those are somethings i loved about
it
you